foreign
so this is a French family that's
vacationing they're staying in Miami
they get this Airbnb and then a
alligator comes and buys a kid and an
alligator came and bit the kid holy no
that didn't happen
[Laughter]
every 80s movie ever yeah
hey kids you want a drug you want a
drugs no they what happened is they so
this French family they have a little
baby 19 month old little baby girl and
then they why they're traveling with a
baby well that's all of your Heroes so
they they end up putting the baby to
sleep uh they lay the baby down I think
like on a couch or a little bed
somewhere in the house this Airbnb
they're staying at and then uh a few
like I guess like a couple hours later
they come back and then the baby is
dying but why did they leave the baby
alone for a few hours well that's
[__] crazy the baby I don't know if
it's a few hours whatever but they put
the baby to sleep the baby goes to sleep
okay okay and then they come back and
then the baby's dying and they do a test
and they realize that the baby died from
a fentanyl overdose what though oh my
God like on the [__] couch or some
[__] they had no leftover overs on the
couch well that that's that's the tricky
part so is it Florida yes in Miami so
what happened is like they it's about
this much fentanyl can kill a an adult
imagine what it tastes to call a baby
probably nothing yeah like a dust
particle it's a crazy thing when I hear
stories like this this makes me want to
be like Republican you know what I mean
that's crazy laws you know what I mean
just get these [__] kids the [__] out
of here yeah so the first thing that the
uh you know when they uh call the
ambulance and then the police the first
thing they do is they have to test the
parents for Fentanyl and then the
parents there's no trace of fentanyl on
anyone else in the house so they but
everyone's like how the hell did this
happen so they go they look through the
records of the Airbnb
they find out the previous uh people
that stayed there had a like a cocaine
field party or something yeah I mean but
no but they what did we say how did they
know that they did it before or
something yeah they're like yeah we had
a cocaine field party so yeah you told
her that they had jobs there and then we
had a party but the thing is that they
can't find anywhere in the house actual
traces offend so do you think that when
they were gone someone sprinkled
fentanyl on the baby
I like where your mind goes but
yeah so because they can't find the
actual Source they can't find the the
actual literal source of the fentanyl
they're not able to prosecute so what
what the family is doing now is they're
suing Airbnb itself what because on the
grounds that Airbnb did not uh clean the
place not the host of the house or the
maid no because ever it's airbnb's I
guess like they're trying to make it on
Airbnb that the place wasn't there
because yeah you're supposed to clean it
you're supposed to conform to like an
Airbnb rules when you're a host I see so
you're supposed to do that and rbb like
charges this crazy [__] charge on
cleaning these and it always smells like
weird ass in the house yeah isn't it
weird where it's like hey it's it's only
like 100 bucks a night here and then you
get the bill and it's like how the [__]
did it turn out to 300 a night it was
like cleaning things yeah yeah cleaning
feet I'm like no I'll
I'll don't trip but it's like or take
how do we take that out anyways but in
this case they that they apparently
didn't clean enough
and uh you're not supposed to if it's
not cleaned enough you're not allowed to
re-list it did the baby survive like
this no the baby's dead the baby's dead
oh [__] that baby the baby died wait a
[__] bomb 19 month old baby you did
like you can't even see it like you just
fentanyl overdose like what so that was
what's scary about that
is that where else is fentanyl like
sprinkled yeah what if it's in a like
how do I know if I get something I can
of something at the grocery store and I
come home and I'm like how do you sound
weird dude yeah remember when we're in
high school it was like Anthrax in the
mail yeah yeah that's this year's
remember Anthrax Anthrax is crazy was
that happening like you cook for a full
whole year
it was the roughest leader of my life
you should carefully open your mail I
don't know if you guys did that do my
dad used to do yeah Latino desert
[__] hazardous but fentanyl is way
crazier than them these did barbecue
little [__] tonsils hey what the hell
the Sun the fact that uh uh the crazy
thing is the fact that an amount that
small could kill this baby but it's so
small that they can't even find traces
of it anywhere Now isn't fentanyl like
the leading cause of drug overdose like
over like the top leaderboard now yeah
that's what I that's what I read yeah
they gotta search the car and they just
sniff in they pass it and they're like
oh [__] and then they die they just got
a cop and said he was in San Diego just
like open the bag and then he just
[__] boom he almost died dude I bet
this happens a lot in Miami right
because Miami's like the co-capital of
the of like the us
anymore that was in the 80s
it could be that most of it's going
through here you know but I mean any
place that has a strong nightlife is
gonna have well they have a lot of
stronger nightlife
Vegas oh yeah I mean yeah dude it's a
drugs in general it's just like people
that just
people like drugs do we make them legal
so we don't have these situations happen
you know is that the thing no make
fentanyl illegal illegal is it well I
think weather is legal or not people
doing drugs that Airbnb I don't think it
affects that you know right no exactly
that's true yeah I don't know what I was
thinking
I don't know what's going with that yeah
that's the situation that that's what's
crazy is that there's nothing that could
really prevent this situation that's
what like Loki is also kind of like one
of those like freak accidents you know
what I mean like when they can't
prosecute somebody it's like nobody
[__] found traces of it anywhere it's
like it's almost like getting hit by
lightning as much as it sucks you know
what if it was in the Uber and nobody
knew that's true like on the way to the
Airbnb the baby got sick on the Uber and
then the baby didn't really go to sleep
the baby was just dying and then so they
put them in the couch and then they it
wasn't even in the house said that prior
it says prior to the baby falling asleep
that the baby was playing it was normal
everything so the baby could have been
playing around the house yeah and then
the fentanyl could have been somewhere
else not on the couch they checked but
they didn't find find it anywhere at all
because this could technically happen in
a hotel room too yeah that's what I'm
saying checking the hotel and you open
the sheets and there's like body hair so
sometimes they don't clean that good I
found one body here dude
and you're like true it could happen
hotel too it would like I remember um we
went to when I used I when I lived in
Arizona I used to visit here I remember
went to Venice Beach and it was a big
ass scene because some lady brought her
kid out to the beach and a [__]
syringe hit his like in Venice Beach
then his Beach heard that uh happened a
lot dude like some heroin out of just
left it in the [__] sand and some kid
like stepped on it and it's like it had
to go go get him to the hospital and get
them tested and see what's going on
evidence is in I'm like [__] that never
when I go to Venice Beach bro I [__]
I wear three socks
I wear cleats in the [__] beach dude
protect from that syringe with three
socks I know that's all I need so what
do you think what do you do if you're
staying somewhere you got a baby like
how do you even
so you just gotta roll with the punch or
something you can do if your baby daddy
just died that's why I make a lot maybe
stay away from Miami for a little bit
yeah I mean maybe don't [__] Airbnb
when your baby's less than two years old
having having a kid though when we
travel like I used to really like
airbnbs but we ended up just doing uh
the hotel route because it's way easier
you know like everyone has continental
breakfast or whatever yeah so that way
instead of like if you're at Airbnb at
secondly to your house so you gotta wake
up and make food yeah but then they
first stayed at a hotel you just go
downstairs you at least grab a banana
and a muffin or something or milk so
it's just faster so I've actually have
an Airbnb uh since we've had Taco going
on family trips and it was it was
actually cheaper than Hotel before and
it was more comfortable now with the
cleaning fee the covet cleaning fee all
that [__] it made it way more expensive
the responsibility I would rather just
pay more money yeah be responsible it's
like you got to pay more than a hotel
but now a lot of them expect you to oh
do this and then clean up it this way
and then make sure you set the TV back
to this and it's like what the [__] man
it used to be like that also hotels will
have like live service you know there's
always that one random room that you
don't go in that room like what the [__]
is in that room no I want to see I want
to go in that room now I'm over there
with the [__] room
because when I when I when I was
managing the Airbnb I was in that room
no way I was in the secret room that
nobody would really know and then
sometimes I'd [__] up and make too much
noise and then people go hey there's a
guy in there and then they would all
like gather outside the door they'd be
knocking on it and they're like hey is
there anyone in there you want a beer
you want to party with us wait wait wait
wait wait wait time out there's a guy in
the Airbnb that's him sometimes
sometimes what if you need to pee or go
out
if I open the door
and I saw this
at my Airbnb dude I would freak the [__]
that's why I would never just first see
you dude dude I would never be seen But
the funny thing is that would you have a
secret passageway to get out of the
house I have my own the homeless man in
my house I have my own sliding door to
get out but then nobody really knows
it's there plus nobody reads the actual
Airbnb info that I am there like they
should know that but they don't read it
all right so the crazy thing people
don't like to read one time I really had
to really make my head hurt dude I
really had to leave the house and
usually I wait till no one's outside to
leave the house right but I really had
to go and these dudes were chilling on
my like uh my front lawn furniture and
[__] they're just kicking it and I'm
like how am I [__] get by them so uh
what I did was I snuck out once
everybody was like out of the foyer I
snuck through the foyer went into the
garage I picked up all these tools and
then I opened the garage door and I'm
like oh hey what's up my maintenance I
was just fixing the tank yeah yeah and
then they were like oh cool see you
later and then I close the garage I'm
like all right have a nice day wow
almost almost two years maybe like not
one person ever like knew I was there
you did it for two years I would have
threw a rock or something so that they
would have been like what the [__] is
that and then they go investigate and
then that's when you can run out what
the [__] what's up with them I would
yeah yeah he never heard me like [__]
weird oh I've I've seen you're just like
I have seen and heard the craziest [__]
like cool like what yeah like uh oh man
so the we can't have cameras anywhere in
Airbnb other than entry points of the
house or exit points so like a bathroom
yeah
it's right there in the [__] room
on the Hooter shot yeah on the bidet
yeah yeah there's a there's a camera by
the back game so if someone's like
hanging on the back gate I can see them
or if they're in the front yard I can
see that
but like there was this one like weird
uh uh corporate retreat with like 25
dudes and one like little person and
they made the little person put a uh
like a basket on his head and stand in
the middle of their Circle and they were
just throwing ping pong balls into it
and no one was laughing what the he was
going like this turning and [__] and
they were just a corporate retreat I
don't know
household that's called a spectrum dude
yeah
for sure at a Latino household that's
called a baptism
yeah and then that's weird and then
another time there was there's one where
it was like all women that had rented it
out and then uh we got a noise complaint
but I didn't uh the cops didn't didn't
come someone had just called like the
district police officer called me was
like hey it's pretty loud I was like all
right uh I think they'll quiet down and
then he came the next day the next
morning and he came to talk to me
because I have a good rapport with him
and he's like hey you know what's going
on here last night I'm like no what and
goes I went to the top of the hill to
like look into the house because you get
a perfect view of the top floor from
like the mountain across okay and he
goes there was an all-women orgy oh [__]
and he was like
What if that was there for three hours
he's so pissed if I didn't intervene
it's like hey do the old maintenance guy
yeah I would have showed up with a
[__] hammer
who's ready to party who wants to get
fixed it's like just crazy [__] supposed
to get nailed
[Music]